We've talked about what orders are and
we've talked about what happens to
them when they get to the exchange.
Let's talk now about how do the orders
get to the exchange from you.
Well, here you are with your laptop
connected to the internet and
you've just entered
an order to buy some stock.
Your buy order goes over
the internet to your broker.
Your broker in turn is connected
to several exchanges and
the broker determines
where to route your order
based on information it
knows about the exchanges.
Let's suppose the exchanges we're
looking at are New York Stock Exchange,
NASDAQ and BATS.
For the stocks you want to buy,
each one of these exchanges
has its own order book.
Your broker has a computer located
at each exchange and it queries
the computer to say, hey, look at the
order book and tell me the prices there.
Query has added all the exchanges and
your broker gathers and
examines that information and
based on that,
routes your order to the exchange
that has the best price.
Let's say that's
New York Stock Exchange.
Your order enters the exchange,
gets executed and the price comes back
to your broker and forwarded back
to you and you get a confirmation.
Now it turns out that because this is
happening constantly all the time,
there's multiple brokers,
hundreds of thousands,
millions of people making
orders that the order books at
each of these exchanges
tends to be pretty similar.
In other words,
the prices don't differ much between
one or another and it's this
sort of pressure that keeps prices the
same across these different exchanges.
Let's consider another scenario.
Suppose there's another client
of this same brokerage, Joe and
that Joe wants to sell some stock.
Well, the brokerage can observe, hey,
I've got some clients who want to sell,
some clients who want to buy.
I can just make that
exchange internally and
I don't even need to
go to the exchanges.
This can be advantageous for the broker,
because a broker doesn't have to
pay now fees to the exchanges for
this transaction to occur.
However, according to the law,
both the seller and
the buyer have to get prices that
are at least as good as they
would've gotten if they
had gone to an exchange.
And eventually, at the end of the day,
this transaction has to be registered
with one of the exchanges.
Usually, it's recorded at the exchange
where that particular stock is homed.
Let's consider one more example.
In this case,
Lisa also wants to sell some stock, but
she uses a different broker than you do.
There's one more kind of entity
out there called a Dark Pool
that acts as an intermediary
between brokerages and exchanges.
So the Dark Pool is looking at the order
books of the various exchanges and
they're often making predictions about
which direction stocks are going to go.
They actually pay the brokers for
the privilege to look at the orders
before they go to the exchanges.
And if they see an advantageous trade,
they'll go ahead and take it.
So in this case,
this cell might be routed through
the Dark Pool from broker
two to broker one.
And again, the transaction never
makes it to the exchanges.
In fact, these days,
80 to 90% of what they
call retail traders orders
never make it to the exchanges.
They're either executed
internally within a brokerage or
filled using a Dark Pool.
The brokerages in the Dark Pools
argue that, that's just fine,
because both partners in this
transaction are getting prices at least
as good as they would get at
the exchanges on the order books.
But they're saving money, because they
don't have to pay the exchange fees.
We've talked so
far about how the exchanges work and
how the order book facilitates
transactions at the exchanges.
Now we've talked about how
orders get to exchanges or not.
Now, let's take a look at how hedge funds
can exploit inefficiencies
in this system.